I flew here and this happens to me all
the time maybe you guys can relate but I
was going to the TSA machine with a big
one where like you put your hands at the
top and they see like your tampons and
stuff and as I was going through the
woman stopped me and she was like excuse
me miss we have to stop you your butt
set off the machine yeah you guys know
what that means don't you
it means that this ass is a threat to
Homeland Security you'll see your future
so I know some you're like oh that's
gross I won't hear about that but let me
tell you guys how good this is okay I
think I fly out from Madison Wisconsin
to Los Angeles California for this on
Spirit Airlines okay now if you haven't
flown spirit before basically they have
catapulted a Greyhound bus into the sky
now they're just like yeah whatever we
got there 15 bucks let him die so I went
through an omen she's like we have to
pet on your buttocks and like a normal
person would be like yes of course
officer do what you have to do but my
response to somebody wanting to touch my
button public was to go yeah and then
turn around and wait and then I turned
her and I was like and I'm like I'm cool
with this like I'm a confident fat girl
right but no one believes you when they
say that there was like okay prove it so
I did I wore a cropped up on TV showed
my guts and everything and people are
like oh my gosh you're such an
inspiration when I was like why I ran at
a fabric that's it like this is a
child's medium that's why SpongeBob's on
it and they're like well aren't you
scared of the online trolls and I was
like I'm not scared of trolls the last
time I got trolled the guy was like uh I
can't imagine trying to sex with the
folds of her fat and I was like but you
did so I win
it's a total double standard cuz I know
a lot of skinny girls will take
Instagram photos of like their boobs or
butt and people are like oh what a [ __ ]
there's such a [ __ ] I do it and they're
like oh good for you how do you do it's
so confident that disgusting body you
live in every single day Wow I'm trying
to be a good role model but what I'm
trying to do for my little sister right
if she has questions about what it's
like to be a woman I answered very
honestly she was like hey Jenny why do
you have hair on your legs and I was
like well Olivia when you get older
you're gonna get lazy next question
then it's just like hey Jenny why you
broke all the time and I was like that
is a funny story because you see
sometimes and you go to college your
parents help you pay for it and then
sometimes they have another kid
she's gonna be weird no matter what I do
right cuz she's got old parents right
like you guys remember when we were
young like we'd run into our parents
bedrooms cuz we had a nightmare both her
parents have CPAP machines now if you
don't know what that is that's basically
after 50 your body tries to kill itself
every night and you have to wear a dumb
mask over your face and your body is
just like and you're like no no no I
have a prescription so she'll run in to
see these two Darth Vader's zombies just
asleep from the bed like she's like it's
how much sure what the ghosts I don't
need this I try to keep her spirits up
right cuz we're getting some dark times
so when I feel bad I sing but there's
one type of music I won't do I won't
sing country music sorry I find it very
offensive like the guy will be singing
about how much he loves his lady and
he's like I got a woman yes and she cute
I like to watch her in the kitchen
making me soup but I don't know about no
Woman Suffrage all the knows of like her
booty hanging at the fridge yeah I got a
woman she loves to cook and clean I love
her so much that I've killed her hopes
and dreams and later on we're going to
make baby
and my truck is made out of beer that
every country
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you